Pete: Hey, it's Pete.
I'm here in New York.
And today we're talking to Dag from Tapad.
Dag's the founder and VP of engineering.
Thanks for being with us, Dag.
Dag: Thank you for coming.
Pete: So, first of all, tell us a little bit
at a high level, what is Tapad?
What do you guys do?
Dag: So, Tapad is a cross platform, or I'd
say multi-platform advertising company.
We're what's called a demand-side platform,
so our customers are the actual advertisers,
and they buy advertising through us.
We're in what's called the real time bidded
space.
This means that we are constantly processing
a lot of potential buy opportunities for ads,
and we figure out in real time if you want
to buy an ad and how much you're willing to
pay for it.
And then we figure out which ad, or which
banner, or whatever you want to place there.
And we do all this in real time.
So it's low latency high, throughput kind
of business.
Pete: Okay.
And tell me about the mobile aspect to your
business.
Dag: So the mobile aspect is, there are, have
been mobile ad networks for quite some time.
Which are fairly, maybe not unsophisticated,
but the mobile space has been lagging behind
in terms of the progress that has been made
on the online display space so, in the past
few years.
So, especially, on the side of a real time
bidding.
So we're trying to bring some of the more
sophisticated use cases, or uses of advertising
technology, to the mobile space.
And we also allow customers to do cross-platform
targeting so you don't have to go to one provider
to buy mobile advertising, and to another
one to get the online display.
We're more a one-stop shop.
We do interesting things based on what people
are doing on their mobiles.
We can use that for targeting them on their
desktops and vice versus, which has started
to resonate really well with a lot of advertisers.
Pete: Okay.
So technically this means that because you
guys are doing real time bidding, there's
a high volume, low latency requirement for
your architecture.
Is that correct?
Dag: Yeah.
So basically how it works, is that whenever
an app or mobile webpage or a traditional
webpage is being served there can be multiple
ad units on the page or in that app.
As the page is being rendered or as the application
loads pretty much, we have to make a decision
or the whole network or the whole system has
to make a decision, which includes quite a
few jumps from, let's say, a mobile website.
They call an ad exchange, the ad exchange
calls us and a number of other vendors or
demand-side platforms, and we all look at
the data that we're getting.
We compare that to the campaigns we're running
and we return basically a bid, saying, OK,
this impression is worth this much money to
us.
And all this has to happen before the user
actually notices because you don't want to
show a page with a lot of white blanks on
it, or on some sort of spinner, loading thing.
So, the requirements are pretty, pretty strong.
You have to respond within typically 60 milliseconds
and this includes network round trip time,
so the total processing time is very, very
short.
And I mean there are companies that have higher
volumes than we do in the online display space,
but we are currently processing about 25,000
requests per second on our servers.
Pete: And that's one reason I heard that you
guys actually made an interesting decision
to move off the cloud.
Can you talk to us a little bit about that?
Dag: Yeah, I mean, we started out as a lot
of companies on Amazon Cloud, and so the EC2
Cloud is excellent to get started.
And makes it very cheap to start running a
service.
Generally though, running on a public cloud
where you have a lot of shared infrastructure
makes it hard for you to really find the hot
spots, find what's costing jitter in your
performance.
So when you're running on virtualized hardware,
you're running on shared network infrastructure,
you're running on typically shared storage.
And we're also, we're a JVM shop, so we also
have garbage collectors which add to the whole
mix.
If you have too many moving parts it makes
it really hard to pinpoint where are our main
sources of performance issues.
Are they something we control or are they
in the actual infrastructure?
And we realized that in many cases this was
actually in the infrastructure.
I'm sure you can cope with that in many ways.
To us being able to respond on a timely basis,
every single time is very important.
So, to us the average response time doesn't
really matter much.
What matters to us is how many requests or
how many incoming requests are not handled
within that very stringent time that we have
to process it.
And if we are losing ten percent of all requests
we're having a very high latency on our ninetieth
percentile.
That it actually might be ten percent loss
business for us.
Because we cherry pick every single request
and if we miss one out of ten, that's ten
dollars, basically.
The other factor is actually in terms of cost
we see that we can, when you start scaling
up a little bit, start buying more specialized
hardware, more expensive hardware then very
quickly you get a better performance ratio
with your own cloud.
And we also have some hardware that you don't
even get in the cloud at all.
Like we're using solid state discs for our
key value stores.
And we also have some, on the analytic side,
we have some very, very high memory type hardware
and memory, RAM is something that's often
very expensive in the clouds.